et maintenant on passe à un autre tu es
au top
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
aussi maladroitement soir donc
tout allait bien
d'après tient année votre huitième année
sur m6 où vous présentiez le meilleur
pâtissier et là en soir après le
tournage nicolas de tavernot le patron
de la chaîne m6 a refusé que vous en
portiers chez vous les éclairs au
chocolat
et je suis parti et vous n'êtes pas
c'était insoutenable c'est le gramme
et
c'est pas ça en fait d'un vieille mère
dans le temps où cyril lignac qui dit ça
manque de croquant qu'est ce que cette
course est grave ces croquants gourmand
il a déposé la presse et croquant
gourmand et 500 après comme aller comme
je l'avais déposer la voie
en maintenant la vérité vraie c'est
xavier marre de prendre du poids
j'étais enceinte je me pèse trois fois
par jour et je pars en vacances avec ma
balle en main est ce que j'ai pu dire ça
j'ai toujours était ronde et ça fait
trente ans que je suis des régimes donc
le meilleur pâtissier
c'était un peu ici la voix thierry votre
problème ce n'est pas que jean pierre
pernaut s'ennuie votre problème c'est
que ça se voit
non pas maintenant j'adore
l'aviez pas marre du du trio le marchand
cordula plaza xoko les chouchous de la
direction les experts non c'est vrai que
en effet m6 a une culture qui fait que
les experts sont les vraies stars de la
chaîne c'est sûr quand on est animateur
sur m6 c'est un petit peu plus compliqué
il y en a de moins en moins d'ailleurs
ils revendiquent et l'arrivée aussi de
david ginola ou là ils prennent de
charme pour présenter une émission de
télé c'est pas son métier même si je
pense qu'elle va faire très bien joué ça
prouve en effet la vision de l'animation
qui n'est pas aujourd'hui quelque chose
de prioritaire voilà et puisqu'il faut
dire surtout faustine c'est que votre
graal votre rêve absolu c'était surtout
ça le présenter une émission de
témoignages c'était de devenir evelyne
thomas
il fait très bien et qu'il a très bien
fait de venir jean luc delarue parce que
c'est vrai ça quand j'étais étudiante en
journalisme défi l'interview de jean luc
delarue et vous lui avez dit à l'époque
jean-luc morale c'est de devenir toi
c'est de faire ça se discute j'avais dit
un jour jean-luc j'animerai l'émission
de témoignages du service club et je
n'avais pas 20 ans tellement
prémonitoire nous avons encore la
cassette audio exactement dans mon
bureau précieusement ce que c'est
quelqu'un que j'admirais énormément et
aujourd'hui c'est la boîte de jean-luc
de les réservoirs qui produit votre
émission du lundi au vendredi à 13h 50
sur france 2 on regarde à quoi ça
je suis tombé sur une conversation avec
une fille sur son ordinateur une
conversation intime alors oui du coup
voulu en parler vous mettez les pieds
dans le plat c'est lui qui est venu un
soir à la maison il est rentré du
travail et il me dit écoute c'est fini
j'annule le mariage on arrête et voilà
il pesé combien votre bébé à la
naissance 7 134 g il a déjà failli
mourir à
ckoi la première couche à joris pour que
vous voyez comment c'est trop on dirait
presque une petite rue de poupées la
question peut-être c'est qu'elle et son
idéal de femmes alors quel est votre
idéal de fès de phage le fort de france
vous ai compris
[Musique]
on voulait faible sur france 2 voilà
bénite l'arène je préfère tenter des
choses que d'avoir des regrets vous
savez c'est exactement ce qu'a dit
hitler avant d'envahir la pologne
après les gâteaux donc vous n'avez pas
peur que ce soit dur de supporter des
cas sociaux parce que c'est vrai que
jean luc delarue on a souffert que
frédéric lopez est parti parce que c'est
très dur dans le temps de tous les jours
les malheurs des gens comment vous allez
faire il faut être drôlement heureux
dans la vie pour supporter jean ballard
est complètement alors il ya deux choses
déjà n'y a pas que les malheurs parce
que c'est une émission là on voit des
larmes mais c'est aussi une émission
très positive on rigole on sourit il ya
aussi des rebondissements dit mais en
tout cas ce sont des histoires de v ça
c'est sûr on se le prend en effet de
plein fouet et c'est vrai caroline got
et xavier couture quand je les ai
rencontrés ils m'ont demandé si j'étais
armé je m'étais pas posé la question
jusqu'au début des tournages et c'est
vrai que c'est compliqué et on a intérêt
à avoir une vie privée extrêmement
solide ce qui est mon cas ben lobb
vie privée non mamadou koné sélection
c'est pas du tout une émission au plan
de la ville et des gens a dit ça va
comment avec maxi ça merci vous embrasse
non mais sans rentrer dans le détail
quel est votre fréquence côté
il ya sept ans mais alors ça va pas être
une émission un lexomil non surtout pas
et ça c'est vraiment ce que j'ai vu à 15
puis j'ai un coach j'ai vu en effet
énormément de psy mais je pense qu'on
est tous passés par là je trouve que
l'introspection personnel c'est un
voyage extraordinaire que tout le monde
devrait faire je ne sais pas mais tu vas
voir un psy j'imagine non c'est le psy
qui vient me voir
c'est
maintenant reconstruire le puzzle de sa
vie un moment c'est ce qui va pas on a
juste envie de vous qu'on vous aide à
voir comment on peut faire pour aller
mieux donc moi le côté on ouvre la boîte
de pandore et on ressort la mer les
relations machin j'en ai un petit peu
marre et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui j'ai
trouvé quelqu'un que je trouve assez
formidable coach que je vois
ponctuellement bien quand il faut elle
embrasse bien regardant le sabbat le
seul truc compliqué ça va être le jour
où vous aurez le témoignage d'une
certaine sophie des qui viendra raconter
comment une fille m6 lui a volé son
initiation alors c'est vrai que ça lui a
volé son émission toute une histoire
s'est arrêté ça a été repris par
frédéric lopez et j'ai pris la
succession de frédéric lopez qui a
décidé d'arrêter donc en rien j'ai pris
la place de ce cadre et on s'est parlé
il est blanc et je lui ai toujours dit
qu'elle elle faisait une émission voilà
voilà donc tout va bien alors que
derrick lopez lui disait qu'il avait du
mal à être confrontés à la douleur au
quotidien il parlait de ses audiences
[Musique]
alors on me dit dans l'oreillette celles
affichant un nouveau truc il ya une
fiche non quand on arrive elle affiche
noire voilà ce qui se passe
la maille
lâche moi
aussi j'ai construit qu'érige montant de
loin est ce que vous avez peur du noir
pas du tout au contraire est-ce que vous
éteignez la lumière pour faire un bon
pas du tout au contraire tu veux tout
voir je vais tout voir tout sentir bon
roman le montage est
bien leur métier aux audiences ça va
mieux ça va mieux ça remonte tous les
jours on grapille après il va falloir
aller chercher les gens un par un
puisque la salle en effet c'est un petit
peu vide et donc il va falloir qu'on
nous laisse du temps solution mais
rétablissant mille feux y rester et on
va essayer de voilà de consolider tout
ça tout va bien tout va bien
[Musique]
comment se retrouvent s'il a la
charge le film c'est un film
ces deux seules de vannes mccoy sais pas
si la musique d'un film alors barré
seulement environ ce feu style en faire
une interview frédéric lopez
[Musique]
c'est mark fields est bien installé
boulade je vous prête mon gilet en laine
faustine je suis extrêmement heureux et
honoré de vous recevoir
merci d'être là faustine merci aussi à
vous christophe et jean pierre avoue
aussi jeune homme
savait que pour nous ça compte beaucoup
vous soyez là aujourd'hui
faustine avant de commencer cette
interview des tirs voulait pas un plaid
on va parler de votre arrivée sur france
2 c'est delphine ernotte qui vous a
appelé personnellement non pas du tout
c'est caroline got et carole univers
d'accord voilà à 39 qu'est ce qu'on se
dit dans sa tête là je suis moi c'est
vraiment frédéric lopez qu'est ce qu'on
se dit dans sa tête à ce moment là
comprenez la question
moi non
[Applaudissements]
ça veut dire faire de la médication avec
moi dans la taïga n'ont jamais levé
heures de rennes ça me plairait botteur
la méditation avec christophe même si je
trouve ça très étonnant de l'assumer de
le faire en public tout à l'heure quand
même dans les coulisses d'europe 1 quand
on vous voit comme ça faut oser se
tasser enfin faut pas avoir peur du
regard de l'autre j'aimerais qu'on en
parle crise
ouais
vous pénétrez du cul je ne pensais pas
être filmés mais j'ai bien noté la
volonté de faire de la méditation
ensemble c'est une bonne nouvelle
des romans d'horreur qu'il faut on peut
décider à peu près comment vous faites
pour vivre avec lui à dire une fois il
est venu ici m'avait expliqué xavier
fait l'amour dans un signe vous m'avez
demandé si j'aurais été capable de faire
l'amour dans un septuor je vous ai
répondu que oui donald fehr
l'enterrement de sa grand mère je trouve
ça un peu
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu